entrepreneurs and business owners my
name is alex ramose and
in the last four years we've done 120
million in sales across my four
companies i have nothing to sell you
i just want to share some of the lessons
that have worked well for us in this
time period
so one of the questions we get is like
how do i make more money right and a lot
of times people think about acquisition
stuff and sometimes it is acquisition
based
but the other half the equation is
making the customers more valuable all
right one of the key ways of doing that
is delivering more valuable services
right and so
services in general right you can think
about this from a consulting basis you
can do
this from a service page whatever right
so this is not for physical
product-based businesses it's for
service type
businesses all right and so what i want
to walk you through is what i call the
service delivery cube
it's cubed because there's six sides
you're gonna see the chart that i'm
showing you right here is six
but i'll walk through each one of them
this is a creative process
that i use when i'm thinking about how
can i experience product lines
what thing can i do with the existing
resources that i have that can provide
more value to my customers
and you'd be amazed that if you walk
through this cube so many opportunities
will jump out at you
using what you know excess capacity or
or sawdust right so if you if you were
if you had a lumber mill
and all you do is you sell lumber
there's all this sawdust that comes up
on the ground
and it's like how can we monetize the
sawdust right we could we can make
sandpaper out of it we can put it into
pellets so that they can make pellet
stoves
right so how can we how can we use what
we already have without incurring more
cost and drive more value to our clients
by repackaging the same thing and so
this is called the service delivery cube
all right
so there's there's six components to
this one is
the ratio all right which is
what's my client ratio for a service
what if i wanted to do something
one-on-one what if i want to do small
group what if i want to do
one to many all right one two unlimited
amount
so whatever i'm doing now i like to
think about is there a way that i could
do this one-on-one is there a way that i
could do this in a small group is this
way is there a way i could do this
one-to-many right so this is the first
kind of filter that i'll look any
any service or potential other offering
through
the next is what extent is my client
going to be involved is it going to be
do it yourself is going to be done with
you right
where we're going to help them implement
you know a change of some kind
or it's gonna be done for you it's hands
off they just pay us money and they get
this result
all right and so these are varying
levels of value and service
all right what's interesting about this
one is that i i like there's another
video i'll make it another time called
the sales to fulfillment continuum but
basically
the the the harder the easier it is for
you to fulfill the harder it tends to be
to sell
and so do it yourself is one of the
hardest things to sell to someone
because it's such
low value because all of the efforts on
them done with you
is a little bit easier to sell uh
because you have a little bit of an
educational component so they feel like
they're learning the skill
right and it's a little easier for you
to fulfill on and then
finally the easiest thing to sell is
done for you because someone just gives
you money and they get the result and
it's the shortcut right but this tends
to be the most operationally complex
there are you know billion dollar
companies in each of these in each of
these spaces they're just
very on you know the more do-it-yourself
it is the more of a marketing and equity
company it is
uh the more done for you it is many
times these types of companies can
provide such
such value that people just come to them
right and so
that's the second of the service
delivery cube the things that i'm
looking at so i might already have
one of these is there a way i could go
up or down on this scale
right the third is what i would consider
support level all right
and where they're going to get support
all right
so are they going to be supported in
this process via text are they going to
be supported in this process via chat
there could be some process via email
via via uh you know expert
representative via phone via zoom
what's the channel or channels that
they're going to have access
to me and my team all right
excuse me the uh the fourth
is going to be how do i want them to
consume the information
all right so if i'm going to have some
sort of service delivery there's going
to be some sort of onboarding process
right
do i want this to be live right do i
want this to be recorded
do i want this to be written right do i
want this to be
do i want this to be audio right like if
you're listening on the podcast i want
to have like audio book versions
of this do you want this to be video
right and all of these things can be
live or recorded so those are kind of
the variations in terms of how i want
them to consume right this is the
consumption piece
consumption consume the information
right and so we're going through the
service delivery cube so i'm thinking it
what is what's the ratio and the thing
is is all of these are a lot of
variables and that's okay the point is
that if you already have something
you can look at where it fits on all six
of these things and say can i move it
one to the left or one to the right
right and if you think about it that way
you'll be able to
excuse me a little tickle there
be able to come up with a new product
that might be more valuable and maybe
even less cost to you
right and that's what we're trying to
find is i want to unearth
where there's hidden value within my
company using the existing resources i
have
that can drive more revenue and profit
to the business all right the next is
speed and convenience
all right so one of my favorite sayings
is that fast beats free
and so if you look at you look at uber
people could walk they take uber you
look at fedex they could use us postal
service but instead they pay more to get
it overnight
spotify there was free free music on the
internet but it was a pain in the ass
you know download all that stuff
instead spotify came in and it was you
could pay to not have the
have the inconvenience right so speed in
and of itself is something that people
will pay for
all right so is there a way that i can
can i that i can cut the results in half
the time
is there that i can speed up my support
so maybe i have
normal support which is you know you get
a repo apply at 24 hours
but then i have vip support which is you
get a response in 60 minutes or less
right so it's all my existing resources
but just put and repackage in a
different way with a different
expectation for the client
right and a lot of people will pay for
that so that's an easy one that we can
deliver value for
all right so it's the fifth one and then
the last one
excuse me is more of a mental exercise
which i call the one
10x to 110 all right and this is a
creative process that i like to think of
which is
if i were to 10x my price of this thing
what else would i
include right what else would i be
willing to do right
and on the flip side if the price of
what i if i did was one tenth
if i if i had to fit it into one tenth
of price and i had to deliver more value
than i am right now
how would i do it and so there are two
those are two creative questions from
different ends of the scale
so if i had a thousand dollar product
for example if my thing was ten thousand
dollars
what would i be able to do that i'm not
doing now right and a lot of times some
of the creative ideas you have you could
actually still do right now at these
price points
and figure out how to jam pack more
value into your offering and on the flip
side
if i offered my product for 100 and i
said i had to make it more valuable than
it currently is
what else would i include what else
would i build into this thing
right and so by thinking through both of
those processes
i can usually come up with new ways to
repackage my products and offerings and
services
uh to become more valuable all right so
the service delivery cube
the reason that i go through this is
because i want to see how i can find
excess capacity in my business to
generate more revenue and profit without
taking on more expenses reliability
and i look at where my current products
exist on this cube
and think could i go one to the left or
one of the right on any of these six so
i'll say them again from the top
we've got the ratio of is it going to be
101 it can be small group is gonna be
one of many
i've got what what level of effort are
they going to be putting in is it do it
yourself done with you or done for you
right can i move either way on this the
third is going to be what level of
support or what channels of support
excuse me
are the clients going to get are they
going to get only only text are they
going to get
only phone calls are they going to get
phone and call or can i have different
levels
based on these channels like we have our
lower level which is just email and
we've got a higher level which is phone
and zoom right the fourth is gonna be
how i want them to consume this do i
want this to be a live experience or is
a recorded experience
do i want this to be written audio or
video how do i want them to consume
information for me as a business fifth
is how can i make this more convenient
or less convenient how can i make this
faster
for them how can i increase the speed of
communication with them right how can i
deliver that
in a way that's going to be in a very
real way more valuable people pay for
speed
all right one of the easiest things in
the entire world is look at any service
category that exists and see if you can
deliver the result in half the time
just focus on that right i mean amazon
prime think about it they they created
an entire
a movement you know with it they they
change they transform the entire
ecommerce space simply by saying we're
gonna get stuff to everyone in two days
right now one day and now hours right
and then finally the creative process of
10x to one tenth
if i had if i if i were selling this for
10 times more than i am right now
what would i include that i'm not and
then can i include those in my current
offering because i just didn't think
about it
and then if i had to deliver more value
than i currently am and i was
excuse me do this for one tenth of price
what would i jam pack into that thing
and so this is the service delivery cube
hopefully you found this valuable so i
don't choke on myself
from this tickle that i'm trying to keep
down use this
think through it and if you're if you're
meeting with your team and thinking how
can you provide more value
this is one of the easiest cubes that i
like to walk through so lots of love
keeping awesome get you on the flip side
like subscribe
comment tell me some questions uh and i
will post some answers
to them so keep it awesome catch you
soon bye